welcome to this video playing five
minute game against random move and play
opens sleen with a six the night off
okay h3 is a recent relatively recent
trend but it's an would move resume even
has been played a couple times x by x
Fisher and this even a game Fisher
against against I think night off
himself where b5 night defiles played
quite interesting if it takes e4 knows
queen anne three this is this is very
strange though because after c4
blakiston and some trouble already it's
got a bad bishop on d7 enter hmm ok
Queen a phone immediately now okay but
this is this is good don't need to be
fancy here
yeah one problem is how to develop the
bishop olive eight that's really only g6
as a possible move and at the end
there's always this week is subchannel
amazing be sure d 2 is going Quincy five
yeah really cannot cannot believe that
check so how to how to publish this just
be should be 3m so the easiest
or is this something out there's also 96
of course but it's only not as good as
it looks at first I just night b3
eventually night b3 might be 30 should
be three heads both grader yeah it's
both excellent Quincy ater the only move
hmm
yeah Queen a 70 okay maybe queen 87
black resigns hmm this was Holly okay my
position is like a dystrophy but oh no
he's backing up I wanted to show
something I'm not quite sure what he's
doing yeah but ok let's err yeah this is
a classic classic game fish I against
night off I night takes d5 already as a
big mistake and he is moving now Jack I
think black is Bastion already the
compass on plus free after that lets
just castle for example something like
this it's just it is just too much this
kind of stuff like it's just exploding I
think you're simply taking on d5 is bed
and you can even a think argue about b5
nowhere no modern player assess is
playing b5 they all play 60 e5 or g6
sometimes alright thanks for watching